la mobylette a suivi une sacrée cure de
jouvence le vieux 49,9 lui a vécu
changement d'époque égal changement de
look mais là bob cancer de son passé le
plaisir de rouler ensemble avec les
potes bref de se sentir libre quant aux
filles si elles préfèrent les scooters
après tout c'est leur problème
c'est la vitesse surtout
beckham
aussi
le fait pas marche à pied tout ce à quoi
on aime mieux accélérer que pédaler ou
marcher c'est mieux quoi mais paul
l'essence aussi ça coûte cher qu on sent
bien
on s'arrête on pouvait repartir il faut
faire ce qu'on veut quoi avec mobile et
on roule bien
ensemble avec des copains c'est mieux
que
ça fait une super sensation quand on est
en en groupe
c'est bien
[Musique]
il
la mobylette véhicules de liberté pour
rouler entre copains avoue tout de même
qu'un poil mieux mais attention on ne
met pas n'importe quoi comme essence une
mobylette ça s'entretient
ok rouler en liberté entre quoi pas
c'est bien mais les filles dans tout ça
méfiance il te reste pas trop parce que
c'est surtout les scooters ouais c'est
sous les crs qui est
ce qui est cool quand on s'assoit fin
c'est super que le scooter tout ça il ya
les amortisseurs ou au culot bécane
comme ça s'intéressent pas trop que ça
fait un peu indépendante comme ça ouais
ouais j'y voyais pas leur place du sud
voilà
[Musique]
ça s'est
vu la mécanique à quelques copains il
fait ça ensemble on démonte on monte des
petits gadgets tout ça on apprend en
même temps on démonte toujours évolué
toujours à les rendre meilleurs
[Musique]
rouler entre copains c'est d'accord
faire de la mécanique entre copains
c'est d'accord mais si vous voulez bien
roulé en mobylette il faut quand même
penser à la sécurité
quand nous en roule déjà on met le
casque budget allemand parce que
lionel enlève tout pour respirer tout ça
mais en vérité c'est qu'on protège
esprits au départ on n'était pas voulu
jouer debout dans une mobylette et
aucune autre sécurité que le casque
[Musique]